Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in
chapter number 73.
verses number 10
through 14. Verses number 10 through
verses number verse number 14.
[Silence]
for
Cathil.
Yeah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says to the prophet sallall.aii wasam
after commanding him with standing for
salah at night.
He dictated to him the amount of
prayer the type of prayer the recitation
of the Quran with a heavy focus on that
etc. the etiquets of reciting the Quran,
the wisdom behind some of these
rulings. He said to the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
with respect to his antagonist because
if a person has an enemy, an antagonist,
they are
going to be prone to wanting to
become obsessed with their enemy.
They are going to feel constantly like
every moment that they spend not
focusing on their enemy is a moment
their enemy is going to get the best of
them. Right here Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is telling him at night when your
enemies are asleep
stand in prayer
recite the Quran contemplate its
meanings. He teaches him the etiquets of
recitation. He teaches him the wisdom of
choosing that time.
A person may say, "Well, what about my
enemies? What about my enemies? What
shall I do with them?
I'm here praying and they're out there
plotting and planning and preparing."
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
He says, "Be patient
with what they say
and
boycott their company."
boycott their company in the best of
ways. Abandon them in the best of ways.
So
this tells us something very important
and that lesson is that patience
is not to be confused with inaction.
There's a big difference between
patience
and inaction.
in action. A person just throws up his
hands and is not waiting for any
opportune moment. Person just allows
life to happen to him.
However, patience
is a
calculated
a calculated act. An act when a person
deliberately can do something but
chooses to refrain from doing so in
order to in order to either take in more
information about the issue. Wait for an
opportunity. Wait for the proper time or
moment or occasion etc. Patience is not
in action. Patience is action.
And sometimes patience is all that we
have.
But most of the time patience is the
best that we have.
Notice this here.
Sometimes
patience is all that we have. We have
nothing else we can do about a
situation.
However, most of the time patience is
the best thing that we can exhibit.
in
most situations.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam taught
his companions along these lines. He
said,
he says
a lesson and most of what he says are
the lessons that were taught to him by
Allah in the Quran.
He said
calcula being patient and calculating
and being very deliberate
in the Arabic language is that a person
take his time in making decisions, take
his time in doing things, take his time
in coming to conclusions.
He says
is good in all things
except the acts of the hereafter.
Except the acts of the hereafter meaning
doing what Allah has clearly obligated
fulfilling a command. You don't have to
calculate anything. You don't have to
consider anything. You don't have to
take your time with those things because
we know for a fact that those things are
good and wherever we can do them, we
take what we can get our hands on.
However, in all other things, he says,
I want to ask the brothers here, , do
you guys have any sayings this,
, idioms or, , as they say ,
proverbs in your culture, your
respective cultures this,
right? take your time or don't rush
or
look at that. It even rhymes. Huh.
Hang on. Hang on. I got to I got to
translate these. I'm translating for you
now. All right.
It says that
[Arabic recitation]
brings always brings regret with it.
However, in taking a person's time, a
person will usually be spared and
right, every every delay actually brings
with it something positive. And and
I hear that one a lot. This is getting
closer to my home now, which is that
patience is the key to
to relief. The key to the relief of
a a crisis.
Another one that I grew up with was
You guys heard that before?
Alhamd she used to tell me this all the
time as a young man growing up you
know ready to come out of my skin to do
all kind to do everything right rushing
into everything a bull in a china
cabinet she used to tell me
that haste comes from aan you know
what's interesting about that that's
actually a narration
an actual wording of the narration is
that
patience and taking a person's time
being calculated is from Allah and haste
is from a shaan. This is in all affairs
except for the affairs of the hereafter.
All right. the reason I ask this is
because
especially those of us who come from
Muslim countries, right? Grow up as the
10th or 15th generation of Muslims
wherever we come from.
Many things that
we practice in our religion
eventually work their way and become
part of our culture to the point that
even our it shapes our idioms, it shapes
our proverbs, it shapes our sayings, it
shapes the way that we see the world.
And one of those is that a person not be
rushing in making decisions, in doing
things and saying things, right? The
wisdom that Allah imparts upon the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam here is
he says be patient
in what they say. They're saying things
saying he's crazy saying he's a liar.
They're saying he's being taught these
things. He's being fed these things.
He's being used by people that are not
from here with malicious intentions
and he's too naive
to see that he's being used. Right?
These are the things that he's that
they're saying about our prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. And they're
saying it at night, they're saying it in
the day, they're whispering,
right? And a person has the drive or
has the the impulse to go out there and
defend himself, right? To go out there
and, you know, maybe if I just say the
right thing at the right time in the
right way and maybe if I just pour my
heart out enough, I can change these
people with my words. It's not how the
world works. And that's not part of the
plan.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells him what
to do with his time and then so that
that question comes up. I'm in here
praying they're out there doing god
knows what. I need to get ahead of this
thing. No. Don't think that when you're
praying that you're wasting time or
you're allowing your enemies to get the
upper hand. That's not what's happening.
Because patience is not in action. While
they operate mainly on emotion and
impulse, you operate on revelation and
control.
That's not inaction.
That is action. That is the best of
actions. And that should be your default
action in any situation. Your default in
any situation is pump the brakes.
Let us see what's going on here before
we make any decisions. Right?
And this is the behavior of those who
have learned wisdom. They're able to
control those emotions.
For instance, anger. We all get angry.
All of us. And the thing about anger is
when you're angry, it affects your
logic, but you don't know that it's
affecting your logic. The things you say
to yourself, it sounds really co correct
and it sounds convincing and logical,
but even you would disagree with
yourself when you're angry.
Therefore, what do we do when these
emotions present themselves?
anger, despair, pain, depression. The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam prohibited
that a judge make a judgment while he is
very angry.
That he make a judgment while he is very
happy. We're speaking about a Muslim
judge, not someone who's trying to
reinvent the wheel. We're speaking about
a a man who has spent the better part of
a century studying the words of Allah
and his messenger. The judgments of
Allah and his messenger. Even he is not
to make a judgment while he is angry.
That the prophet sallall.ai
am
a judge is not to come to a conclusion
while he is angry. And so when a person
finds himself overwhelmed with a
particular emotion,
those emotions that come and overwhelm
us, they're a monster that comes
around to be fed. You can't feed it when
it comes. It tells you, "If you just
feed me, I'll leave you alone." It
won't. It won't. If you let that monster
out of the cage, imagine with me you're
sitting in a room full of cages. These
cages have the most terrible, ravenous
monsters in them. One monster is anger.
The other monster is desire. The other
monster is joy. The other monster is
elation. The other monster is
depression. The other monster is
overwhelming sadness. Right? When you
walk into the room, they all beg you and
sweet talk you to just let me out for a
few minutes. Just let me stretch my legs
a little bit. So, let me come out and
just stretch my legs. I promise I won't
hurt you. I promise. Right. If you open
that cage and if you let it come out, it
will not go back in that cage until it
has destroyed
everything it can get its hands on.
And which of those monsters is the most
deadly? It is the monster of
anger, the monster of the tongue. Those
are the the monsters that will strain
constantly to get out of their cages.
And if you allow it out of its cage, it
will run rampant and cause you grief.
Therefore, a person is to exhibit
restraint.
But there is a difference between
restraint and arrogance. There is a
difference between restraint and a
person not speaking when they need to,
not doing what they need to do when it
is time to do it. Right? for
example, let's say you harm another
person and you say, "Well, you know,
patience is good in all things. Let me
be patient before I make things right."
Have them in aan. This is from We heard
that the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam said
right set in the books straight and
balancing
what you're owed and what you owe.
This is something that is an immediate
thing. It is part of the acts of the
hereafter.
And so in this verse the prophet
sallallah.aii Wasallam is being given
words of reinforcement from Allah
that
don't worry that while you're here in
your home or in the night awake
praying and in the daytime having to
take your portion of sleep that somehow
your enemies are going to get the upper
hand on you. No, rather do not for a
moment think that patience and inaction
are the same thing. This is a situation
where patience is called for when you
exhibit your patience, he says,
and abandon them, boycott them in the
best of ways.
You know what's interesting about this
word here,
right? He's telling him to boycott them.
Who is that? Abu Jah and Abu and
Khalif and
leave them. Leave their gathering. Don't
even go there. Stay away from their
gatherings when they're all together
that, a pack of ravenous
wolves. Leave them alone.
And he tells him,
This means that
boycotting someone, abandoning someone,
this is actually a tool, isn't it? It's
not actually a tool. It's a weapon. It's
a weapon.
Is a weapon and an instrument of war.
It's used to inflict pain on other
people.
Where is he commanded to direct this
weapon? To the enemies of Allah. Not to
the Muslim.
Not to the Muslim. You know what's
interesting about this is that Muslims
will boycott each other and they think
that if this person is out of sight and
out of mind, I don't have to deal with
them.
How silly. How silly of you to think
that there is any amount of distance
that you can travel away from someone to
not meet them in the court of Allah on
the day of judgment.
ish.
Allah says that when he resurrects them
on the day of judgment, it will be like
they
the dunya
was only
a few hours of a day
and they will all pick up exactly where
they left off in the court of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
that guy that you held a grudge against
your brother, your Muslim brother, and
even worse if he's Muslim and your real
physical brother, that's even worse,
right? That you spent 30, 40, 50 years
not talking to them.
Don't think that that person went away.
They didn't go away. Even if they die,
even if they're dead and in the ground,
they didn't go away.
As soon as you're both resurrected, you
will pick up exactly where you left off
and now you have to deal with it. Al is
a weapon. And if a person uses that
weapon against his Muslim brother, that
is a major sin.
We all know the narration.
Right? It is not permissible for a
Muslim to boycott, abandon his brother
for more than three days.
Now, what's interesting is another
narration that is maybe a little less
familiar to us. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said,
Sephacade.
Have we heard this narration before?
A Muslim who boycots his brother for a
year or more
is of the same level of sinfulness as if
he spilled his blood, as if he killed
him.
You will come on the day of judgment
having to answer for the murder of your
brother. What kind of murder?
The the metaphorical the the the the
proverbial murder of him, right? What is
the point of keeping his body alive when
you have plunged
your sharpest dagger into his heart?
And so this
is a weapon. It is nothing else. Don't
conflate it with being anything else. It
is a weapon.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam says,
"Whoever carries arms, takes up weapons
against us, he is not one of us.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.